This planet is not
inhabited by evil
spirits, and at the same time, there was something to kill it on this planet.
Preliminaries
[music]
Shaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaa  Tandanoko
[music] The
screen turned into them after death I'm curious about the cities, towns and villages that aren't used to black and white
[music]
I was doing
[applause]
OK I'll use that skin
Kunugi
[music]  ]
Mm [music] tan
It's an act of pompous attack Saki-chan is poor, so Xanadu was there.  Protect
me
hahahahaha
[music]
spray I should have returned to the Kingdom of Suwa
[Music]
[Applause]
ran
Touching scene
[Music]
[Applause]
me
one
[Music]
rar
[Applause]
[Music]
Good
Yes, many times, but
I slept comfortably, so today I'm far away, so I'll definitely wake you up at 8 o'clock,
but it's time
to have breakfast
.  I
'll do my best
[music] [music]
[music]
car yeah yeah yeah
can you do
detarame Who do your best ana
ana
good good good [music] Hmmm, come to the really good Karatsu live today  Thank you
The new gray honey flash curls that just came out don't sound like it
Nice to meet you
[music] I
'm not
alone  I've made a statement twice around this time that I've borrowed it as a charter day.
No, you guys are popular.
[Applause]
6. Hiro was just staring blank, wasn't he?
And the song is a contract with a different character,
so don't get into trouble over what those people
get.
Good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good
) [music]
[music]
That kind of evening drink Yo-chan's big brother is a child's purotan It's
already terrible No, it's amazing Hey, cheap top idols and brothers
What the heck is Saki-chan a childhood friend of the super idol Mikage teaching material?
I was just
following her around.
I haven't gotten close to Mohiro-chan at all, but it's a
glove.
I can't do it, but I'll overtake you 2 There are still many things I need to work on, but
z I hope this kind of day continues
[music]
]
aname
Aburu - It's a nice town
Oh, if you say that, it
's a microcosm of long waves Yes
ah ah ah
[music]
Ha
Okay timer person
Jack was well-conceived Was it
really amazing and mustard?
It's a lie.
is before  If you think you can escape from it, you're making a
big mistake Hey,
it's Asaka around here, isn't it?
Haha, everyone was a girl.
Ah,
you know the symbol of magic,
do
n't you?  I heard that pets were used for something
[music]
Hmm, since then, it's always been a magical symptom.
Ah,
it was a lecture. I think 100 people could see it and say that 100 people are the same person.
I
couldn't create it eo I
was active until recently, but I'm tired.
There's no
magical girl to protect your heart, right?  Eh,
15 Ah, it's the last minute.
Ah ah ah ah
I can split up What the
hell is
this
?  It's the number of days Recently, if the neighborhood's
banalities have been beaten, you can learn
from that pasting system I even have a pass pattern.
Oh
no, it's cute, or rather, I feel like this one is more like a mascot.
- The
sound is determined by your appearance a
This girl is a heavy and ferocious woman With a heavy
gear and a normal attack on youma is a second meeting
If you can defeat the demon king's strengths if it's special a
One of the legal girls is a
good acquaintance or I've already picked it up
I came back from lc 6, right?
Nora it's
search
Oh
well Matters lure
I'm sorry it's a product
Uhirocha Hirochan Hirochan Rokuchan
ana
Rhythm double Earl I
got
it Game over if you get thrown into a lot of tournament gates Oh yeah
I was standing there
Thank you
me
[music]
Even now it's over hula Ah
ah ah ana So which one is it?
yeah yeah yeah yeah
[music]
hmm wh deji good
ran
duhan
[music]
ana
ni
[music] yeah yeah yeah [music]
down girl Standing on the earth
It was the first time I fought and feared a
magical girl close to me Can I survive
[music
] but
pandan